MAJOR MOVE TO INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS.
HE'S GIVING ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR THE AUTHORITY TO DECLASSIFY
ANY DOCUMENTS RELATED TO THE
PROBE.
THE PRESIDENT HITTING DEMOCRATS
AND EXPLAINING THE DECISION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THEY WANT TO
TRY AND GET A DO-OVER OF THE
MUELLER REPORT.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
I DECLASSIFIED, I GUESS,
POTENTIALLY MILLIONS OF PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT I WANT TO BE TRANSPARENT.
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL IS IN
CHARGE.
LET'S SEE WHAT HE FINDS.
>> CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF
RIPPING THE MOVE SAYING "THE
COVER-UP HAS ENTERED A NEW AND
DANGEROUS PHRASE AND ALSO IT'S
UNAMERICAN."
JESSE, NOW THAT THIS
DECLASSIFICATION OF MILLIONS OF
DOCUMENTS HAS OCCURRED, DO YOU
THINK THE DEEP STATE WILL FIGHT
BACK BECAUSE THEY HAVE GOT TO
WORK WITH A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
AGENCIES INVOLVED?
>> JESSE: ALL THE SCOUNDRELS
INVOLVED ARE GONE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT McCOMB ANY,
PETER STRZOK, PAGE, THOSE
GANGSTERS ARE OUT OF THERE.
>> THERE IS THE F.B.I.
>> TRUE, BUT IF YOU DECLASSIFY
EVERYTHING YOU'LL HAVE ACCESS TO
RAW SOURCE DOCUMENTS, FISA
APPLICATIONS AND THE 302s AND
THIS IS WHY THE MEDIA IS SO
UPSET BY THIS.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME DONALD TRUMP
HAS CONVINCED THE MEDIA TO BE
AGAINST TRANSPARENCY.
THE MEDIA DOES NOT WANT TO SEE
SECRET C.I.A. AND F.B.I.
DOCUMENTS FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME.
USUALLY THEY WIN PULITZER
CERTIFICATE PRIZES FINDING THESE
DOCUMENTS.
NOW THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THEM
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
PARTICIPATED IN A WITCH-HUNT.
THEY KNOW THAT ALL OF THEIR
HEROES LIKE COMEY HAS BEEN
LYING.
THEY WILL DUMP HIM AS SOON AS
THE CROSSHAIRS GO OVER HIS HEAD.
>> IT'S EVEN WORSE THAN THAT,
REMEMBER, THERE WERE TWO PARTS
TO MUELLER.
THERE WAS COPLUTION AND THERE
WAS OBSTRUCTION.
SO IF THERE IS NO COLLUSION, HOW
DO YOU OBSTRUCT NO CRIME?
IT'S NOT AN OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> YOU'RE MAKING SO MUCH SENSE.
>> OBSTRUCTION OF INJUSTICE.
IT REALLY IS.
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THAT WAS MY LINE, YOU STOLE IT.
>> I HAD IT FIRST.
THE EUREKA MOMENT, IT CAME TO
ME.
IMAGINE WHEN YOU SEE THAT
MUELLER KNEW IN MARCH OR JUNE OF
2017 THAT THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION, AND DIDN'T TELL THE
PRESIDENT.
SO HE KEPT THE INVESTIGATION
GOING MAKING TRUMP CRAZY SO HE'S
MAKING, TRUMP, FIRE THAT ONE,
FIRE THAT ONE, SO WHY DIDN'T HE
TELL THE PRESIDENT THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION?
BECAUSE HE WAS SETTING A PERJURY
TRANSPORT FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK THESE DOCUMENTS WILL BE
EXTREMELY UNSETTLING FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN PROMOTING
THE WHOLE NOTION OF A RUSSIAN
PROBE.
>> THEY TOTALLY MOVED THE GOAL
POST.
THEY ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
OBSTRUCTION, NOW THEY ARE SAYING
HE'S OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE BY NOT
COMPLYING WITH THE SUBPOENAS
THAT JERRY NADLER HAS ISSUED.
>> CAN YOU MANAGE IF THIS IS HOW
THEY REACTING AFTER THE MUELLER
REPORT CLEARING THE PRESIDENT,
IF IT HAD GONE THE OTHER WAY.
IF THIS IS HOW THEY ARE ACTING
WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS CLEARED
IMAGINE IF THERE WAS SOMETHING
THERE, I MEAN, THERE WOULD HAVE
BEEN MOBS AND PITCHFORKS.
THIS ENTIRE CIRCUS IS DUE TO THE
FACT THAT THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS GOT THEIR ASSES TO
THEM IN 2016.
MUELLER WAS A REPEAT OF THE
ELECTION AND I'M SAYING THAT AS
SOMEBODY WHO DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM
BUT GREW UP.
HE'S MY PRESIDENT.
I DIDN'T SIT THERE --
>> WHO DID YOU VOTE FOR?
>> I THINK I WOE IN MYSELF.
I CAN'T REMEMBER, BUT -- THE
THING IS, AFTER THE
INAUGURATION, TRUMP BECAME MY
PRESIDENT AND I JUDGED HIM ON
DEEDS AND NOT WORDS AND I HAVE
BEEN VERY HAPPY BUT WE'RE
LEARNING NOW, THE TWO YEARS
DIDN'T MATTER, THEY WERE GOING
TO DO THIS TO HIM ANYWAY.
IT'S I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT
TRUMP.
IT'S AND OUR VIEWERS.
TRUMP IS MERELY A PROXY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THE MEDIA
HATES.
TRUMP REPRESENTS FLYOVER
COUNTRY, NONHOLLYWOOD,
NONMANHATTAN PEOPLE WHO JUST SIT
THERE WITH THEIR FINGERS UP
THEIR NOSES, YOU KNOW, GETTING
DRUNK IN THEIR TRAILER PARK.
THAT'S THE WAY THEY SEE IT.
>> WHAT IS THE POLITICAL BENEFIT
FOR DEMOCRATS HERE, OBVIOUSLY
THEY ARE TRYING TO SATISFY THEIR
BASE WHO WANTS THE PRESIDENT
IMPEACHED BUT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY, POLLING SHOWS THEY WANT
PEOPLE TO MOVE ON.
>> THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
JESSE ALLUDED TO THIS, THE PRESS
WILL HAVE TO DO SOME WORK AND
THEY WILL HAVE TO SIFT THROUGH
THESE THINGS AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE WORST PARTS WERE OF THESE
ABUSE.
>> HOW ARE THEY GOING TO SPIN
IT?
>> THAT'S THE PROBLEM, YOU CAN'T
SPIN IT.
IT'S PROBLEMATIC IF THIS IS THE
STRUCTURE AND THE SYSTEM THAT
WE'VE GOT, AND THAT HAS TO
CHANGE, AND, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE
TO APPLY A MUCH MORE OBJECTIVE
LENS TO THIS PROBLEM BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW, IT'S SO INCREDIBLY
SUBJECTIVE, AND PEOPLE FEEL AS
THOUGH THEIR OPINIONS ARE FACTS.
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO ROCK
THE FISA COURT.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S GOOD AND I THINK --
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN INSIDE THE
FISA COURT ENOUGH, AND IT'S NOT
--
>> PROBABLY TRUE.
>> I DON'T THINK THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SHOULD ABSTRACT THINGS
CONVENIENTLY FOR THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK WE SHOULD SEE MUCH MORE
DOCUMENTATION, SEE HOW THESE
APPLICATIONS ARE RUBBER STAMPED.
SEE HOW THE JUDGES JUSTIFY SOME
OF THOSE DECISIONS.
SEE IF THERE IS ANY FOLLOW
THROUGH AND IF IT'S NOT ENOUGH,
THEN CONGRESS HAS TO GET UP OFF
THEIR BOOTIES AND DO SOMETHING.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
NARRATIVE BEFORE WE GO WITH THE
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
WHO ARE NOW, ADAM SCHIFF
INCLUDED, ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT
OF USING LAW ENFORCEMENT AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON NOW AS A RESULT
OF DECLASSIFYING THIS
INFORMATION.
SO THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY
PROJECTING WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING FOR THE LAST TWO, THREE,
FOUR YEARS, ON TO THE PRESIDENT
FOR BEING MORE TRANSPARENT.
>> WE'RE THE ONLY ONES THAT ARE
ALLOWED TO WEAPONIZE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, NOT THE
PRESIDENT.
>> ALSO, THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO CAN
DOCTOR VIDEOS.
THE MEDIA CAN PROVIDE MISLEADING
EDITORIAL BUT NO ONE ELSE CAN.
WE CAN DO IT BUT YOU CAN'T.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> BUT THE THING IS, RIGHT NOW,
THERE ARE TWO THINGS GOING ON